it's not enough just to be a bit
stronger i need to be faster
more agile
more focused
i'm training for the peak of human
performance oh not you again how'd you
get in my house
you can't train everything at once
because you'll die
don't you think people are sick of
batman videos by now
you are not ready
hey
oh you crazy fool
i thought you'd never call
[Music]
so i've been making these batman videos
on a roughly yearly basis for a while
now and the reason for that is not
because i'm a nerd it's definitely not
that it's because batman offers a really
interesting thought experiment how do
you train for optimum performance across
modalities he doesn't just need to be
strong he needs to be fast he needs to
be mobile and it presents a really
interesting challenge
as a trainer
i've had the fortune over the last
couple of years of training with and
learning from some really fascinating
people who are at the top of their game
and their fields so i thought how can i
top what i've done before i'll lean on
their expertise so i'm going to be
visiting
parkour athletes someone who's trained
sealed team six
grant who's a excellent martial artist
i'm gonna be speaking to some really
high profile coaches to get their
recommendations for improving athletic
performance so right now i'm on my way
to see grant
and we're gonna talk a little bit about
the kind of martial arts skills and
training that batman might need
so yeah man um you've obviously made
that really awesome batman
martial arts training video we went way
in depth on on all the techniques he'd
need definitely check that out guys but
if you had to like
really hone in on just a few basic moves
that people should drill when they're
starting out if they didn't have that
much time for the martial arts training
what what are the fundamentals that
you'd need to start fighting like batman
would you say
um
well as we'd determine in the video
before obviously batman's
primary style is boxing so it would have
to be something around the basic boxing
punches and i think the most fundamental
of those the ones that anyone will use
the most is just a simple jabbing across
as basic as that sounds but
those shots are so
versatile in their application i think
to really and it can almost seem like
you're kind of
just repeating something again and again
and again but that's the way to
obviously gain that mastery in the skill
so i think some of the basic boxing
punches definitely jabbing across
obviously and then some of the the hooks
and uppercuts and things like that as
well
and then some of the basic kicks like um
you know like a teep kick or a front
kick
and probably some lower kicks like some
round kicks or something like that would
be really useful as well
awesome man and so like if you had to
pick
like one or maybe two exercises like for
conditioning and strength that would
help someone to improve their
athleticism for those moves specifically
or what do you think of the most
valuable the most bang for your buck
i think
one of my favorites is
the bit of a combination of two so it's
like the jack push-up where you kind of
go down into a push-up and your legs
shoot out so you really have to use your
core to kind of hold yourself in that
low position and then spring back up
again and then i would say using that
into kind of like
a high tuck jump so it's kind of like
combining the jack push up with the
burpee in a way and just because it's
using the whole body it basically mimics
the movements of martial arts because
you know you're using all the different
muscles of the body while you're going
down like i said the core your arms
obviously in that push-up motion and
then your legs to spring apart that i
think that's probably one of the most
beneficial ones that you could do
awesome
[Music]
what's up man hey how
yeah i know i totally haven't been here
yet and i just wanted to like ask you if
you were batman what kind of parkour
move do you recommend training what do
you think
it's difficult to know because i mean
the guy's got a cape where he can just
fly off the building so there is that
but um if i was batman then i'd
definitely i'd like to climb up as you
said i'd want to be able to do any vault
that i'd need to do because that would
be
if anything's coming up to you and
you're like chasing someone you
definitely need to be able to just
quickly spit so speed vault would
definitely be the
vault you need uh and just the ability
to
land in any situation i think is like
absolutely necessary which is why
parkour park is perfect because you most
of your jumps are to the rails and when
you learn to jump to rails
then you can jump to anything the one
exercise you have to pick one one
exercise the most value i'm not saying
this would be their whole workout it's
so difficult uh
can i choose two go and then yeah okay
two so like um
i would say
climb ups but they have to be split into
like two exercises right so that's like
a wall pool which is just like this and
then like a wall dip which is like this
so if i show you i'll just hop up here
just hop up here so you've got a wall
pool which is like this
and then you've got a dip which is like
this and those are the two exercises
that you should work through so that you
can eventually get to this move here
nice which where if you land up onto
anything
then uh then that's
like if you land in a cat grab in
anything you need to be able to pull
yourself up so it's so important to have
that upper body strength in the pulling
range of motion and the pushing range of
motion depending on where you land
and also this reminds me of
a kind of position you'd definitely be
in for batman so you want to be working
on that deep squat as well
yes
you are gonna try
and do a climb up with no tutorial to
start with yeah let's see what we got
this is how i would naturally climb a
wall essentially
nice mate not bad
when you're first starting it is quicker
to grab over the top like you did right
and uh that
only problem with that is scuffs up your
arms and long term it's uh it's like
just not a very fast way of doing it
what our aim of the game is we want to
come pull up the mid stage is to just
slide your hands on top
roll over and then push
so it's like a muscle up with the arms
almost exactly yes
hands are too wide
okay i don't know how you did that
problem is you're about this wide
and when you're this wide you
immediately put pressure on all your
joints all the way around because you're
like here imagine how much pressure you
can actually take there versus like this
nice what yeah quick
so quick i'm happy with that
yes
yes
yes adam hell yeah man
nice dude
[Music]
so now we know how we need to train if
we want to move jump and fight like
batman but that's still not enough
because batman isn't just a parkour
martial artist he finds himself in
incredibly intense situations where he's
under heavy fire a huge amount of stress
he needs stamina endurance focus and to
get these things we need to look a
little bit further afield fortunately i
know just the guy jc santana from the
institute of human performance he's a
luminary of functional training and he's
trained the likes of mma fighters pro
athletes and the formidable seal team
six and i had the nerdy goal to ask him
how he'd go about trading batman
you know so uh if you ask me what's the
most important thing and overlooked and
running i wouldn't even say it's glute
no what would you say
ankle stiffness oh yeah of course yeah
yeah the ankle stiffness oh yeah you can
get you can give a a new car a new
engine everything boom you can give a
person
super strong legs and all that and you
if you put them in the sand
yeah it's over
yeah so this like leads into one of the
questions i wanted to ask you
specifically like it's a broad question
like maybe it's impossible to answer but
if you had like one or two exercises
that you would pick as the most
important all-round athleticism well the
ones that you like come back to most
often i'm guessing car push would be one
of them car push is is the lower body
cardio animal for any any sport or any
activity that that that ambulates
yeah if you're moving from point a to
point b fast
okay car pushes period end of story okay
then the other ones would be a cable
press and a cable run done yeah yeah
cable press uh like standing up for for
the reasons that you explained to the
past like to keep your core rigid and
everything and i would go sing along
single arm i want to ask you a little
bit about like you're training with um
still team six if you're able to talk
about it like what did you do for them
a lot of times we don't get physically
tired
we get mentally tired
and that
super imposes on our physicality
yeah but it's the mind that gets tired
atp stores glycogen stores they're all
there
yeah
yeah
really
so what what do you do to to fix that
well
back to the pre-fatigue stuff that i do
yeah that pre-fatigue is huge if you
want to mimic and it's a situation that
is always under stress well
pre-stress them yeah it's like
engineering total logic right okay how
do i stress them well number one you got
to suffocate the [ __ ] out
a versa climber is always good
yeah a push of the car is always good
because you know that'll do anybody in
yeah air dying is good so i hit somebody
with 30 seconds of a blasting sometimes
two pre-fatigues i'll hit them with 30
seconds of a versa climber go to super
legs
and i'll go 84 reps of super like and
then i still i'll stand in front of a
fighter for example and i'll say when
i'm in front of you with these with
these noodles don't let me touch and
they'll let you touch them i'm going one
part of don't let me run
like dodgeball how would you train
batman if he came into your gym like
he's got to be able to do everything run
across rooftops fight the bad guys gotta
stay focused you know he's basic amount
of strength but
i would train the way i trained seal
team six yeah i would train with
circuits
yeah you know he's got it he's got to
have power because you know there's
sometimes a pow you know you know
yeah of course
sometimes he needs a punch and stuff
like that so you got to train him like
an mma fighter yeah but you also have to
bring in the running because he runs
you know
so right now our new batman program
consists of jackhammer push-ups wall
presses and dips car push cable press
and cable pull we've also got some bag
drills a deep squat sprinting and some
pre-fatigued focus work i also asked
aaron la from invincible worldwide what
his most recommended exercise was for
martial artists we call it the splits
push-up it's inflexible
i think that one exercise is good to
promote strength
good to fix the hip alignment and it's
good to increase your flexibility so we
can throw in this split push-up as well
that's already a beast workout but it's
not yet complete partly because it's not
a balanced routine yet and partly
because it doesn't cover every possible
scenario that batman may find himself in
in my quest for cross modal performance
i devised a system called the atsp
hierarchy this breaks specific talents
or proficiencies down into attributes
traits and skills
so an attribute is a trainable single
piece of anatomy for example big biceps
or an achilles tendon with high
hysteresis a trait meanwhile is a more
global ability this might be something
like good endurance or rotational
strength traits are usually made up from
multiple attributes skills then are an
expression of traits and attributes so
that might mean a golf swing or a putt
and finally proficiencies are hobbies or
talents and these are typically made
from multiple skills but recently i
modified this to create the atnsp
hierarchy i did this for functional
training 2.0 n stands for networks and
it's the missing piece of the formula a
network is a combination of attributes
or skills executed in a specific way so
if we reduce all skills down to
individual attributes we're essentially
training in isolation like a bodybuilder
better than training just the obliques
and shoulders for a good punch is to
train with a cable punch out that works
those muscles together
i recommend coaches to use this system
to train athletes and clients in any
area you can work backwards from the
activity to identify the specific
trainable units you then train at every
level you train the isolated attributes
you train the traits you train the
networks together and you practice the
skills
but to really train like batman to train
as an all-rounder we then need to flip
this idea on its head
now we're going to look at the traits
and attributes and networks that
underpin the most possible skills and
we're going to look for exercises that
hit the most of these all at once
in super functional training 2.0 i
describe these as super exercises super
exercises sounds like a nonsense term i
just made up because it is but i'm
ripping off the idea of superfoods here
just as a superfood provides lots of
nutrients in one go a super exercise
will train multiple attributes and
traits simultaneously what exercises can
batman do that will make him
simultaneously a better fighter a better
runner a better climber and a better
thinker what exercises can prevent
injury whilst also building strength and
mobility
there's another criteria by which we can
consider an exercise a super exercise
that is if it trains a missing trait or
missing attribute these are those things
that we often neglect in our modern
training and lifestyles so for example a
missing trait could be straight arm
strength this reduces the likelihood of
bicep tears during deadlift it allows
for cool moves like the planche and more
rock climbers meanwhile need amazing
finger strength the handy thing is that
there are already some movements out
there that stand out as super exercises
these are the movements that specific
coaches and fitness personalities have
been shouting about from the rooftops
movements that appear to develop freak
athletes
for example we have the atg split squat
heralded by ben patrick niso vito's guy
as a truly game-changing exercise for
building not only incredible athleticism
but also bulletproof knees
ben has been a huge disrupter in the
industry and this one movement
encapsulates a lot of what he teaches
there's four main reasons this ass
tragress split squad is my favorite
long-term athleticism plateau buster
meaning you just keep getting more
athletic over time first is that you're
able to train your knee tendons tendons
are stronger pound for pound therefore
springier than just muscles second is
the vastus medialis so of the thigh
muscles this teardrop shaped one is the
most fast twitch meaning it's also the
one that gives you the most athleticism
per pound and you're able to
proportionally train that third is the
fact that we're able to do this one side
at a time therefore not having major
imbalances between sides so this keeps
us less likely of getting hurt and
fourth is the hip flexor lengthening
benefits meaning this allows me by
getting longer hip flexors to use my
hamstrings and my glutes so i think
that's a sneaky side benefit for
athleticism
and it might be the most important
foundation for lower back health too
or how about the hip thruster from brett
contreras the glute guy so many of us
failed to activate our glutes during
athletic movements and instead rely
overly on our quads rhett was one of the
guys who really brought light to this
issue and he developed this movement in
order to address the problem all right
let's talk about hip thrusts okay
in the preparation of athletes many
exercises that are have been
traditionally very popular train the
glutes at long muscle lengths which is
very important think squats
stiff leg deadlifts romanian deadlifts
you know lunges bulgarian split squat
step ups
these all work the glutes down deep in a
flexed position and that's important you
want you want a muscle be strong
throughout a full range of motion
however
in order to have that full range
strength you also need to have good
lockout strength think about when you're
sprinting when you're propelling your
body forward you have to put force into
into the ground rearward
and the foot touches down you know right
in front of uh your your center of
gravity
you have some initial braking forces and
then you have to reapply
uh propulsive forces you know in order
to keep accelerating or in order to
maintain top speed so it's very
difficult very challenging you need to
have strong glutes at the lockout okay
what exercise are good for that well you
know hip thrust variations back
extensions reverse hypers
even types of kickback
kickbacks can be valuable
and speaking of bridges paul wade author
of convict conditioning swears by the
back bridge as a tool to build a nearly
indestructible spine it's controversial
to proceed with caution but he believes
that it's helped many prisoners to
develop superhuman performance
havel
and many others highly recommend two
specific movements with the kettlebell
the kettlebell swing and the turkish
getup
[Music]
the kettlebell swing is sometimes
described as having the what the hell
effect owing to its ability to improve
everything from running speed to jumping
height to deadlift strength the getup
builds incredible shoulders and a
powerful core it's a favorite among
wrestlers also popular among wrestlers
is the gamma cast which you can perform
using a club bell this was the method
famously used by the great gamma who
went on to perform all sorts of
legendary feats
stuart mcgill the back mechanic talks
about the big three exercises for the
back of those the side bridge stands out
as a missing way to develop the
under-appreciated quadratus lumborum
along with the serratus obliques and hip
abductors as mcgill says proximal
stiffness develops distal athleticism
the entire movement training movement
seems to be in love with crawling and i
completely agree with them crawling
develops proprioception as a
quadrilateral movement speaking of edo
portal believes that everyone should
spend some time in a deep resting squat
which we were also recommended by liam
earlier and some time hanging from a bar
to improve shoulder mobility the latter
also builds even more amazing grip
strength the la land push-up was made
famous by its namesake jack lalanne he
used it primarily as a party trick but
the truth is that it builds an insanely
strong core with no equipment necessary
and it's very similar in many ways to
the dragon flag as used by bruce lee
meditation is helded by everyone this
improves focus willpower and working
memory and of course the big three
movements are considered the big three
for a reason the bench squat and
deadlift let you pile on huge amounts of
weight for powerful muscle and tough
tendons
but we should bring back the military
press too for that vertical pushing
power if we combine all these exercises
with those recommended by our experts
earlier we end up with an incredibly
comprehensive approach to training
all-round athleticism something that
would be perfect for batman
see of course it wouldn't be complete if
i didn't share a few of my favorite
exercises so as many of you know i like
high repetition push-ups fantastic for
building strength endurance explosive
power core strength and the perfect
counterbalance to the high rep push-up
is the bodyweight row
which is an anti-flexion movement
missing from many of our diets and it's
fantastic for scapular control
the l-sit to handstand press
this is a hybrid movement
it's fantastic pressing power core
strength compressive strength
cross body clean and press one exercise
that trains so much rotation
a hinge
a squat a press
and
the cossack squat a rare movement in the
frontal plane
fantastic for hip mobility
the med ball slam essentially
a reverse
vertical jump rotational throw brilliant
building that rotational power and
finally the rope climb excellent for
grip strength core strength
and of course
something highly applicable to the way
that batman
would need to train
yeah those are my picks but obviously
i'm not the only guy who's built his
youtube career around training like
superheroes
there's another guy who we need to speak
to as well
well my personal favorite exercise is a
certain cardio you do with a buddy but
i'm not going to go into that because i
love you by near and i don't want you
get demonetized so my favorite exercise
without a doubt is probably weighted
pull-ups and i love weighted pull-ups
because they are one of the most
functional exercises anyone can master
and learn and just regular pull-ups in
general like and all the variations chin
ups close grip neutral grip all the
variations i love them so much because
not only are they great at building that
mass aesthetics and cobra vibe for your
back but they are so so functional like
there are so many times in life where
you need to pull yourself out of a
scenario or like climb something to help
really get that functional strength of
climbing moving it works your forearms
your biceps your back and some a little
bit of the tricep if you didn't know
that and i think it's just one of the
best exercises everyone should strive to
get down all right love you lat pull
downs but pull ups are the goat in my
opinion
so there you go guys we've now got
enough exercises to build a somewhat
comprehensive routine that i think
covers all of the dynamic performance
that batman would really need of course
this was just a fun thought experiment
in reality you could never create one
program that would cover every single
aspect of human performance and more
importantly that would apply to every
single person when i spoke to jc
santorum about this in more detail he
went and got all realistic on me he was
saying how it would depend on batman's
limb lengths his weight his schedule
even whether he would shoot his
grappling hook with one arm or they
would repel himself up with two arms the
point is you can't create a single
workout that's going to apply to
everyone in every situation and you need
to know batman to write him a perfect
program
i've scheduled this as a ppl fb that's
push pull legs full body split meaning
you're gonna hit every muscle group
twice a week but at the same time you
also have enough time to dedicate an
intense workout for each movement
pattern
all of this is free to download from the
website you don't have to sign up you
can just download the pdf right away
it's quite a basic workout there aren't
any progressions so it's not gonna work
for people at every level you're gonna
have to adapt this to your own needs at
the same time it requires quite a lot of
specific equipment so if you want to see
how it actually trains somebody as many
people as possible for multiple aspects
of their performance then you probably
check out my more in-depth ebook and
training program super functional
training 2.0 the protein performance
system that includes over two hours of
video tutorials it's a much more
in-depth and complex system and at the
same time includes progressions and
easier steps so that anybody can get
started whether you're a complete
beginner whether you're really advanced
at bruce wayne level plus there's an 80
plus page ebook it goes to depth on the
atnsp hierarchy this is where i refined
that system further and many of the same
exercises that i've included in this
workout are included there but with a
lot more explanation and like i say
easier and harder progressions to fit
every need
thank you so much for being patient on
this one guys i don't know if you can
tell but i tried to make it something
really special so i pulled in all this
extra talent went to all these different
locations learn some new skills
and i just want to take this moment as
well to thank everybody who got involved
in this video i couldn't believe the
amazing response i got from nearly
everyone i reached out to so of course
there's grant stevens who filmed some of
this as usual also gave his expert
advice and he choreographed and helped
me film that awesome little fight scene
where he kicked my ass actually really
smarted at some point so thanks for that
grant check out his youtube channel i'll
put that in the description down below
as i will all these things there's liam
ellis from parkour journeys who showed
me his parkour moves also helped some
filming and he has a fantastic channel
but also a digital product that'll teach
you to climb up in more detail so if
that's something you're interested in
learning then head over there and
support him he's a great guy and he does
great stuff then of course there's jc
santana who's been nothing but generous
as always with his time and his
knowledge he is an absolute font of
knowledge when it comes to functional
training so check out his channels again
in the description down below of course
jack's blade he's an awesome guy you
know we see eye to eye on a lot of stuff
we both like superhero training as usual
he was a great sport and joined in and i
really appreciate it ben patrick knees
over toes guy i've been admiring his
work from afar for a while now so i was
super pleased that he agreed to send me
that short clip jam-packed with
knowledge and information so i thought
why not reach out to the glute guy brett
contreras as well who also responded
which was fantastic so thank you so much
for that another massive mover and
shaker in the world of functional
training
both those guys have youtube channels
and instagram accounts again all be
linked down below then there's adam lar
that clip was from a longer interview i
did with him so that'll be coming soon
stay tuned otherwise check him out at
invincible worldwide another exceptional
martial artist huge thank you to nikhil
captain sinbad for his cameo i was
actually inspired by him to create that
kind of trailer-like opening he does
that sort of thing sometimes and i love
his work so it was awesome to have him
as a small cameo there check out his
channel for really inspiring
productivity and lifestyle content with
a real cinematic edge to it and my buddy
janet rajapaksi who's an actor and who
kindly lent his talents for this really
meaty and challenging role i think i
really tested his metal as an actor
and to my wife hannah who also helped
fill some of these shots all of you
awesome and i hope to do more collabs
like this in future too
for now though
thanks a ton for watching and bye for
now
my